chadwick boseman followed in the
footsteps of a whole host of elite
superhero actors by getting seriously
ripped for his role as T'Challa in black
panther but his hollywood fitness
journey actually started well before he
joins the Marvel Cinematic Universe
here's some insight into how Chadwick
got chiseled the path to Panther
T'Challa isn't Bozeman's first
physically demanding role in 2013 he
portrayed Jackie Robinson in the
biographical drama 42 as well as
capturing Robinson's off-field
contribution to the civil rights
movement
Bozeman needed to appear authentically
athletic for scenes on the field to
prepare Bozeman train twice a day for
three and a half months following the
same technique as the pros in an
interview with GQ he referred to the
sessions as madness due to the strain
such activity places on the body aside
from swinging his hips and shuffling
Bozeman's appearance as The Godfather of
Soul James Brown must have been a breeze
compared to 42 right wrong when
portraying a musician as influential as
Brown the pressure is on not only to
sound the same but to move the same as
well
Bozeman had to do the splits while
filming get on up not once but 96 times
the actor admitted that day's shooting
was harder than any activity he
performed as Jackie Robinson secret
training unlike some of his fellow MCU
stars Bozeman has remained tight-lipped
when it comes to divulging the secret of
his regimen when asked by enews prior to
Civil War's release he refused to share
any inside information for those looking
to emulate his results a lot of strength
and flexibility but I'm not going to say
anymore
I can't say or reveal their training
secrets though Bozeman hasn't disclosed
the specifics of his workout plan all
actors in the MCU are notoriously put
through their paces and he won't escape
what Captain America himself Chris Evans
refers to as absolutely brutal sessions
couple hours a day and it was brutal
the tricky part was eating state law
just eating
the collet ah but the key to achieving
Bozeman's lean physique likely lies more
with the classic bodybuilding techniques
including circuit training and a less
substantial diet that still adds power
to Black Panthers claws well Evans
needed to pack on the pounds in a short
span of time Bozeman's goal of remaining
lean meant you could increase his body
mass at a slower rate this meant an
extra emphasis on cardiovascular and
circuit training to burn more calories
for explosive movements Bozeman would
focus on plyometric training which
increases power by working on fast
twitch muscle fibers combat work likely
tops it all off with training in a
variety of martial arts losing muscle
for Marshall sandwiched between
performances as Black Panther Bozeman
played Thurgood Marshall in the 2017
biopic Marshall replacing civil wars
Airport battles with clashes in the
courtroom understandably bozeman would
look out of place as the future Supreme
Court justice if he maintained the mass
so to fit tailored trousers and well
fitted Blazers the actor needed to strip
away 25 pounds of hard-earned muscle
between the wrap on Marshall and the
beginning of Black Panthers production
in January 2017 bozeman needed to
recover lost muscle mass to ensure his
shoulders could carry the weight of
expectation for his return as T'Challa
with the added spotlight and increased
screen time Bozeman's training regimen
will presumably have been even more
intense than his Civil War workout but
the principles will remain the same a
gradual progression of lean mass thanks
for watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]